yesterday we were talking about
something called strass
how generational theory and according to
that theory which
was developed some time ago about 25
years they say that we are in the fourth
season the winter period
where we'll be entering some kind of
crisis on that show we talked a lot
about what that crisis may be
and we should be in the peak of it so
perhaps it's some kind of
internal conflict here in the u.s but
there's also something called thucydides
trap which suggests we may be
looking down the barrel of war with
china strass how generational theory
could be predicting that maybe
the crisis we face is world war iii or
some kind of large international
conflict and that may be china
so one of the we have a bunch of
different stories pulled up one of which
is about
china wants to teach young men
masculinity
because they're scared about changing
gender roles that's something very
different than what we see here so maybe
the crisis we're facing is
multifaceted well we're going to talk a
lot about china today and what's going
on with the biden administration what's
happening in the south china sea and
taiwan and hong kong
and pineapples apparently getting bought
up like crazy
because war can be weird and we're
joined today by the crew from china
uncensored so why don't you guys just
introduce yourselves and let everyone
know who you are hey tim good to be back
i'm chris chappell the host of china
uncensored and america uncovered
i'm matt ganesa the producer of those
shows
and i'm shelley jong the humor ninja of
those shows
yeah official title official title i
like it
so we're going to talk uh just a lot
about china i guess it'll be the friday
what's happening with china episode i
suppose and i think it's it's probably
important too i'm glad you guys came
because
before joe biden got elected there were
a lot of questions about what we might
see
under a biden presidency with policy
towards china
and you guys were mentioning that some
of the people he had in his transition
team were very
favorable friendly towards what china
had done what they would do
probably doesn't sound all that good for
us so we'll get into all this stuff
before we do however head over to
timcast.com become a member because
we've got a ton
of exclusive members only posts when you
become a member
you provide that safety net in the event
that we get banned because
it's entirely possible we do but we got
a ton of really awesome guests though
we've got exclusive segments and
episodes with people like ben stewart
jack murphy ryan long
cassandra fairbanks we had james o'keefe
sydney watson and you can even see this
one right here look at that
i'm holding up the official hour pillow
prototype something i know all of you
are very excited for so make sure you go
to timcast.com
become a member and don't forget to like
share subscribe if you really do like
this show and you're listening on itunes
or spotify
leave us a good review it really really
does help let's talk about this first
story and uh before we started the show
i asked you guys if you if you
if you knew a lot about the gender role
stuff the culture war stuff
and then a concept in the context of
china i think it's
really really fascinating what's
happening in southeast asia in general
because i think shel you mentioned like
k-pop and stuff and how they're they're
you know kind of worried about it over
there
let me read a little bit from this
article from nbc news and then we'll
just we'll talk about it
nbc reports china proposes teaching
masculinity to boys as state is alarmed
by changing gender roles boys in china
traditionally are expected to be strong
leaders
get good grades and excel at sports but
the gender balance in china is changing
they say they start with this like i
hate when journalists do this out with a
story
no one invited boo younhau to be in
their group for the annual class trip
the other fifth graders at shanghai
shangdi experimental school
made fun of the 11 year old calling him
too girly quote i wanted to run away
right out of the classroom
said yan hao now 13 in a first year
middle schooler in shanghai
some of his classmates made fun of his
high-pitched voice and the way he
screamed when he tried to maintain
discipline
among his fellow students as a class
monitor others teased him for spending
so much time with the girls
and said he acted like he was trying to
date the other boys in the class
the bullying eventually stopped but a
recent announcement by the government
that singles out boys who don't fit
traditional chinese
ideas of masculinity has revived the
painful memories
the plan to quote encourage masculinity
in male students
has inflamed a debate over modern gender
roles
as china's government increasingly
emphasizes what many consider to be
outdated and
damaging stereotypes for men and boys i
think it's interesting because that
perspective is
wholly american like in america it's
very much
i'm reading the story and it's like if
that happened now there would be a psa
they'd bring in bully experts and then
say no no it's okay that he's he's
effeminate and things like that
but it also reminds me of that
commercial that we saw in uh out of
china a while ago where they put the
black men in the washing machine
and he comes out as chinese people in
the united states were outraged how dare
you you're so racist
people in china laughed and didn't seem
to care at all so i i wonder what you
guys thought i don't know whoever wants
to jump in about uh
you know the gender roles in china and
what you guys think is happening
well one thing that jumps to mind is you
know back in the cultural revolution
uh it was sort of the opposite where
they were making an effort to like
completely eliminate any kind of gender
like the women had to dress
in uh almost like military attire
very baggy had to have short haircuts uh
any kind of display of femininity was
not allowed
and now similar now i guess right uh
well i think the women are
allowed to be and encouraged and that
reminds me of the guy who had a
was found out to have 100 mistresses i
think he won he wanted them to be very
feminine still ah
he got executed by the way well that
escalated quickly
it did well i mean there's also a lot of
corruption so it wasn't yeah
it was also the three metric tons of
cash they found in this oh okay okay
yeah the product was like a guy who's
like i want a bunch of women off with
his head
no no word on what happened i believe it
though yeah yeah i don't know where the
mistresses are but yeah shelly you made
a good point about uh sort of the
influence
of south korea on china yeah i think the
thing is that with
the growing like k-pop cave dramas like
this whole korean wave coming in like
that
there has been kind of more like
the a more effeminate kind of male has
been like the
ideal in movies and music and all this
stuff and it's affected
china a lot and in response the chinese
communist party tried to
basically have their own like patriotic
boy bands and they love that one yeah
and then it's it didn't quite
work well but they're trying to like
basically use
um like chinese culture to fight this
like
incoming korean like popular culture
that they didn't like
and then you've also got this so like in
chinese the word for like
the type of like effeminate like male
like these like really pretty
young men is called like small soft meat
like small tender meat so that's
so that's become like super hot and then
the chinese communist party is like
that's not
masculine enough meanwhile the chinese
communist party is making movies like
wolf warrior right like they want like
the chinese rambo
that's really it's really weird though i
mean they're communist and then in the
united states
the the right criticizes all of this
stuff by saying
those trying to strip away masculinity
are communists right so we had jack
murphy on the show recently
and he went uh you know he went on this
tirade about
marxism is inherently anti-masculine
because they want to get rid of the
patriarchy and things like that
but how does that make sense that the
communist party of china wants strong
burly masculine men
and they're literally the communist
party
it's like well there are different
different tactics to communism and in a
communist country like china
they want a big fearsome military that
intimidates
other countries uh china is definitely
gearing up for the day
they invade taiwan they've been very
open about
wanting to invade taiwan they've said
this for decades and so
i think this is partially a response to
like
creating an image internationally of
like this is a fearsome
military force that will be able to
uh take taiwan don't mess with it in the
south china sea
but but does this have anything to do
with what's happening in the u.s are
they responding to
what's happening here i know you guys
mentioned korea right
is it isn't a lot of what happens in
korea related to
you know they want to sell to america
they like the culture that america
exports they try to adopt certain things
like that
like boy bands weren't invented in in
korea yeah
they i don't know if they were invented
here in america mind you well uh k-pop
they definitely were obviously inspired
by the american music industry but i
think they've been
fairly unsuccessful at really
penetrating the u.s market
outside of like uh bts or like gangnam
style
which was but sai isn't like
he's not the typical he's not a bts
right he's not a serious it's like very
hokey and silly and like he's making fun
of it kind of yeah so i don't know you
can say that like
uh that korean style is appealing to the
us because it really hasn't
done that yet yeah even though there's a
lot of good k-pop out no but i mean like
is korea trying to be like the us in
terms of how pop culture works right
they're they're emulating
a lot of countries do this america has
some kind of pop culture phenomenon and
then you know they emulate it
i mean we emulate a bit of the british
stuff too when we've had various
different artists come from the uk
i'm just wondering if china's reaction
to this and and the things they're doing
is countering the united states right
like i was saying about the communist
thing they're looking at
are are they looking at the u.s and
being like we're going to do the
opposite of what the u.s
is because the u.s is bad how kind of
like how tribalism works
i actually think they're kind of trying
to do the same thing that the us did but
in like the 80s
like they want to use you know
soft power to project like the way that
you know american blue jeans or
i brought up a rambo right like like us
this
or top gun like these type of like um
movies that like
celebrated they love top gun like this
kind of
masculinity that that kind of like power
like that appeals to the communist party
because that seems like
it's like oh then you have the power to
like wolf warrior was about
you know these chinese uh soldiers who
went to rescue chinese citizens
who were you know in africa right so
like they were
uh you know the whole idea was like the
motherland will never leave you behind
like it was this like whole like
very patriotic yeah it's like 80s yeah
yeah
and and the whole idea like the
communist party uses the propaganda of
the century of humiliation
constantly the idea that you know
foreign forces have humiliated the west
and so china needs to be strong we need
to be strong and
fight against the hostile foreign forces
so what do you think the sentiment among
the chinese people is though
i mean it doesn't really sound like the
communist party is communist
that's a big conversation so you know
there's a lot of elements to communism
and a lot of people think
oh communism is about the the
says here's what products have to be
made and who does what jobs
right and i think that's that's true but
that's only a
you know five percent of what communism
is you know ultimately communism is
about
power and control for the communist
party and so they'll use
these ideas of creating a utopia on
earth and and you know you know how it
goes
uh it ends up you know they promise
equity they promise equality
uh and ultimately you know some animals
are a lot more equal than others right
that is the leadership of the party
um what we see in china is a
there's a lot of capitalism going on in
the sense you have a lot of private
industry now and you have in the last 40
plus years since the
giga kaifung their reform and opening up
from started in 1978
huge explosion in private industries but
the reason china is still
completely a communist country is number
one
the communist party actually controls
all those private
industries so uh you've got uh
you know alibaba uh you know the
uh dalian wanda the film company you
know any any company has to have
a communist party branch in the company
that's even funded by a company and
they're involved in
big decisions that are happening in the
company in fact even foreign companies
that go into china like mcdonald's ikea
they all have
party cells in the country by law they
have to have party cells
in the company and so there's there's
that control of private industry on top
of that
you've got some of the the biggest
industries in china that are directly
state-owned enterprises steel coal
uh telecommunications uh some of the
construction
so so that element is communist uh and
then on top of that you've got
the sort of communist uh legal
system which is that they don't have the
kind of legal system we think of here
you've got obviously the rubber stamp
congress
but you also have the way that they rule
is not through rule of law
they have they rule through these mass
political
campaigns which is you know a whole
other topic but
like simply put you know xi jinping will
say something like
you know we need to improve the quality
of
public toilets in china and then like
everyone in china has to get involved in
like sprucing up these things and some
local officials go nuts and they build
these like
you know million dollar golden toilets
you know
for foreigners look how great we're
following this this policy this
political but it's a political campaign
you know private companies have to do it
local officials
and you get promoted based on how well
you follow the policy
and even if the policy is is ludicrous
or even if you take it to an extreme
that doesn't matter because you know
you're as a local official you're not
accountable
to voters you're accountable only to the
higher-ups who are giving you your
position
so in that sense it's it's still
completely communist even though you
it seems to have the elements of
capitalism who was it michael bloomberg
who said something about how xi jinping
has uh constituents he has to oh he yeah
he said not a dictator right yeah he's
not a dictator yeah right so
so he doesn't you say he doesn't have
voters michael bloomberg disagrees
sort of i mean is there a possibility
that
if the people are upset xi jinping will
not be in power well let's ask the
uyghurs
i don't i don't think that like but like
there is like there is this you know
this whole populism versus the elite
thing that's happening
basically all around the world uh in
china
the communist party is like uniquely
positioned to take advantage of it
because they're a communist party so
they already say
you know it's the people's this the
people's that but
xi jinping has specifically made an
attempt to be
a populist leader within the communist
party even so
he'll do things like his anti-corruption
campaign which was really about kind of
getting rid of his political enemies but
a lot of it
was positioned as like we're getting rid
of like the
excessive like elite communist members
who are just
you know wasting money and drinking and
having mistresses and those kind of
stuff
and then he'll be photographed you know
uh
take eating steamed buns at a like an
ordinary restaurant with the common
people
or like you know these kind of like very
guy you could have a bi
joe with yeah like he's a guy you could
eat a steamed bun with it's like very
like
maoist in that way or it's like man of
the people type of propaganda so he's
making a specific play to become the
populist leader
i think prior probably partly because of
the the power struggle that's going on
within the party so he kind of
understands that like having he needs to
have
you know the ordinary people on his side
quote-unquote yeah well that's what
drove the cultural revolution mao was
kind of on the outs
he used the love of the people
particularly the psychotic young youth
activated them and then he was
back in power basically so that's
powerful do regular people in china like
generally speaking the communist party
or xi well they'll certainly say so
publicly hard to really know
what the opinion is because there there
is no forum
that they can really actually clubhouse
was kind of an interesting example
of um maybe some signs of descent like
clubhouse uh
there were mandarin language chat rooms
that would like
very very quickly fill up to like their
five thousand person
max capacity and this was like for a
very brief window i think it was only
about a week
or so it's like it was the weekend it
was a weekend
when i shut it down it was just like
this little bit of crack where
people inside mainland china could have
actual uncensored access to the outside
world wow and they were talking about
xinjiang
and the uyghurs and the concentration
camps and all this stuff they were
hearing from uyghurs they were hearing
from people in hong kong in taiwan
and so i think that was a that's a sign
that people
in china are aware on some level that
they are being starved
of information yeah and they're going
for it but also people on clubhouse like
you're talking about you know
wealthy chinese people or upper upper
middle class
rural farmers you know yes exactly yeah
i mean my experience mainly with
overseas chinese people
is that they've generally been uh seem
to be positive towards the communist
party
and i think that's a lot a lot of times
because you have a a very small subset
of people that end up making it to the
united states
uh and the reason they got their wealth
so they could come here is actually
because
they had connections within the party
and many of them
were party members themselves and so so
you've got like a very
a small and non-representative subset of
wealthy or influential overseas chinese
who were saying
we like the communist party or they'll
say oh maybe there's a few
issues but basically it's been really
good for china well you're talking about
the people who have come here within the
last like
10 years the last 10 years right and so
but then you have like
if what you're really talking about is
the other 1.3 billion chinese people
you may have a very different
perspective and i remember uh shelley
when you were
talking with blind chinese uh rights
lawyer chen guangcheng about
what was on the ground in china yeah and
he talked about how you know
many people are very fed up with the
chinese communist party they just cannot
express it online because they know
i mean people have been arrested in
china for calling xi jinping a steamed
bun
for example or winnie the pooh right
yeah yeah so it's not
it's not a joke that like people are
seriously getting in trouble for what
they say online
yeah yeah well it's happening here now
just in different ways i think it's
interesting how
we've basically just outsourced
censorship very different from what they
do i mean for them it's the communist
party that dictates the censorship right
mm-hmm
here it's just oh oh we can't interfere
with what the monopoly
wants so now you look at how every
all the conversations here are being
controlled it seems like there are there
are parallels
not completely identical but still some
similarities where people are getting
you know it's getting worse and worse
here well tim they're private companies
they have the right to you know monitor
their own businesses
don't you support billion-dollar
conglomerates like google
see that's the issue it's it's always
the the centralized power
if we give all the power to the
government you'll end up with a similar
problem
however we have a bill of rights in this
country so there's at least that to
protect us
in the event that in the us we say okay
we're going to nationalize or regulate
these companies
but you'll still run the risk no matter
what the supreme power is the the
centralized
unified authority no matter what it's
what it is it's going to tell you you
can't do things it doesn't like
well i mean the foundation of the united
states is the idea that absolute power
corrupts absolutely so it's a system
in place to prevent the elite from
getting
too much power because what always
happens is the people who become elite
think they should have more power
and have a general disdain for all of us
other schlubs yeah but but they know
better than us chris
should we let them tell us what to do
and what to think
my problem with the elite is they don't
recognize that i should be amongst them
yeah right yeah jerks i know i have a
very high iq i'm sure
my mom told me yes yeah well to to to
islam
to a certain extent i mean the communist
party is just the elite the people who
choose to join it do they're doing so
because they know they will get
the elite ranks the privilege the access
they use they use the same line that uh
communism has used all along that
there's class struggle uh
the world would be a better place if
there weren't this group oppressing
everyone else
uh and so they are the people and then
they
uh kill everyone they well they kill
they kill the bad people
and then take over and then obviously
since they're the good guys
they can do whatever they want and
everyone has to that's right
and it's hard when you uh get into power
uh
on the premise that you're fighting
those in power
because then you don't want people to
fight the power when you become the
power
right well then they just have to to
come up with a group to target
right so you know you target the
students in 1989 and they become the
the pariahs and you massacre them
there's always some enemy to fight right
in the late 90s the enemy was
was falun gong but uh you know they then
killed them for their organs and
there was the tibetans which they've
been targeting for a long time and
now that they've run out of the falun
gong organs they go to the uyghur yeah i
mean and actually you know we had a
guest on our show talking about how like
there's not a lot of falun gong
practitioners in china anymore of a
certain age group
because so many of them have been killed
for their organs and now the communist
party has just
moved on to a new group to get new
organs
what do they what do they use the organs
for transplants i mean yeah
i think for like the people they like
for party members which are people who
can pay for it
it's commercial it's commercial i mean
look at a human you know uh
you know a human heart could be retail
for a hundred thousand hundred and fifty
thousand
a set of lungs hundred thousand dollars
dollars
yeah i mean so the the the value of a
human life in china
is very specific you know it's about 450
000 that's how much a human being is
worth
on the black market of of oregon trade
well not the black market because the
point is
chinese state-run hospitals and so like
what's happening
with the uyghurs like we know about the
concentration camps right we know about
the
uh the how they're treating women and
and so on
uh but the thing that's not reported on
very much is
in xinjiang it is very likely
that a lot of those people are being
used as sort of a human organ bank
and when there's someone who wants an
organ they find a match from within that
concentration camp system
and they will do a speedy match and
there's a lot of you know i don't know
if you want to go into it but
here but there's a lot of evidence to
suggest that
they are in fact using uyghurs for that
and it's coordinated by the same
system that is doing the labor camp so
it's all part of the
the party's plan this is not some black
market
group or whatever doing it it's a fully
coordinated effort it's the way that
they subsidize their
medical system because the government is
not paying for it right anymore
they're not paying for the medical
system well it's sort of socialized
health care but like that's not really a
very accurate way to describe it because
it's very misleading
so uh well it's socialized medical care
but it's not
very good but also like the the state
isn't really giving it much money and so
it has to support itself through
the hospitals are yeah kind of they need
to make their own
hospitals need to make their own money
and one of the key ways they do
that is through transplants so so
whenever we hear this argument that
you know the united states is one of
like three countries without universal
health care or something
china actually doesn't provide that kind
of coverage for people yeah well i mean
it's they purport to do so but the
problem is that like
like you can go to a hospital uh and
that'll be provided but you'll you'll
still have to pay for your own food in
the hospital you have to pay for your
own nurses in the hospital
uh like there's a lot of things about
that system that don't work you have to
buy your own medicine it also depends on
who you are and where you are and what
kind of publicity there is going on like
during covid there was a lot of
the the the country is paying for the
medical care of these people who
are getting the credit is for everyone
you know yeah okay that's different
yeah that was for americans actually
yeah foreigners
yep yeah you want to go
well it's funny that you know look we
can talk about chinese china anal
swabbing american diplomats or whatever
but we are talking about organ
harvesting which is like
a little bit worse i would say it's a
little worse yeah a little bit huh yeah
yeah
like a lot of it worse but that system
the organ harvesting system has been
going on for a long time and as i
understand it it really ramped up
in the early 2000s because they had all
these falun gong
in prison and so they're like well what
are we going to do with all these people
and they're super healthy because
they've been doing qigong
so wow you got you've got healthy people
they don't drink or smoke
they're in good physical shape perfect
yeah we want them to be like 28. and
they just we're talking just billions of
dollars i mean this is really about
money
you see that china did ramp up the
construction of
uh specialty hospitals designed
specifically for organ transplants and
this is at a time
when there is no organ donation system
in the country
wow yeah there's for a lot of cultural
reasons and whatever like
maybe in china all across china like a
few hundred people
or at most a couple thousand people are
like
volunteers like organ donors and the
system isn't even really functional in
most parts of china
so the vast majority of organ
transplants are from
non-voluntary donors and there's they're
not even
executing enough convicted criminals to
account
for the tens of thousands of transplants
that are happening every year
and so like these organs have to come
from somewhere and the
the reality is almost certainly that
they're coming from
uh one or more repressed groups falun
gong probably the biggest
uh maybe uyghurs now uyghurs uh because
there's not
enough falun gong uh organs left uh you
know to some degree tibetans and house
christians i think
you mentioned that the the falun gong
are healthier is that is that
similar for the uyghur muslims they
don't drink things like that
with the wii u it seems like there is a
specific uh
they they call it halal organ right for
the customers in the middle east
yeah there seems to be a specific desire
for that in
those communities because they don't eat
pork they they're they don't drink
right and and so that so that's why
there's advertising
for medical transplant tourism in the
middle east to come to china
and there's even at the uh the airport
in
urumqi which is the main city in
xinjiang a sort of like fast track organ
line you can you can google it and find
photos of this
just like to speed up anyone who who's
boarding a plane who's carrying organs
uh so they're attracting middle eastern
customers
who are they're very ethical customers
who only want halal organs from muslims
ethical very ethical because they will
they want the halal organs yeah but
then they're alive harvest the organs of
this innocent muslim as well
it's unclear if the people getting the
organs how much they know there's a
certain
degree of willingness i don't know i
don't want to know
yeah like it is not possible to
order an organ you you can't schedule it
two weeks in advance
except in china you can though wait wait
wait wait wait china you can schedule
you schedule it on a day
typically like about two weeks yeah have
you guys ever seen the movie the island
with uh
yeah who was in it was it uh leonardo
dicaprio no
no no no no no mcgregor yeah
and they're basically their clones so
that when when their
non-clone counterpart in the real world
needs an organ they harvest the clone
yeah so it's like you could order
as a wealthy person be like i'm gonna
need that you know heart in a few months
and they would be like okay and they
would start prepping
the clone for for harvest yeah i i
wonder
you know i'm not a muslim but i wonder
what the actual
scripture says or the teachings would
say about being a muslim
and then going and then having a country
that is subjugating muslims
taking their organs and then you as a
muslim are like i'll take that organ
i can't imagine that's right in like
in their religion you know what i mean
yeah but people within the same
religions have been killing each other
for
centuries so i mean there's always that
but i i think that the
the people who are going to get the
organs i think they typically
aren't thinking about the source they
don't want to think about the source
and no one is helping them think about
the source
and so it's just like oh i'm just going
and getting a transplant
and that's a voluntary donor that is
what they will be told
yeah they will be told it and like and
they might have their suspicions but
they don't want to think
you don't want to let your mind go down
that path yeah right i guess when when
people are faced with death they need an
organ they'll believe whatever they have
to believe to justify their existence
i mean but like also the western you
know
medical system is supporting this uh and
they don't have the excuse of the fact
that there's
they're facing life and death because
the transplantation society has
willfully not looked into this and have
been like
uh like we don't see anything wrong
happening in china and you know there's
been a lot of brouhaha over
china has done a lot of cutting edge
organ transplants
are like cutting edge yeah organ
transplant
research a lot of like leading edge
research yes
so like you know a lot of the new drugs
that are coming out that make
like taking organs out of people like
easier
like letting the organs survive longer
outside the body
these things are all coming from china
uh in the last decade or so
and it's because they're doing all of
these transplants yeah and
you know it's it's like a society that
doesn't care
at all about the individual
that's pretty accurate yeah now it sums
it up uh yeah and unfortunately
china is uh trying to draw medical and
scientific talent from around the world
because they have access to a lot of
funding
state-backed funding and there's often
not the kind of moral restrictions
holding them back like in the us for
better or for worse
you have all kinds of restrictions like
stem cell research is a huge issue
none of those kind of moral dilemmas
ever hold back the chinese communist
party
so like shelley was saying they're able
to make these breakthroughs
in organ transplant technology because
they have willing
live don't uh test experiments willing
yeah
willing yeah the communist party is
willing to sacrifice them for the good
of the party
yeah there was the guy who was talking
about head transplants and how he had
practiced it several times on oh yeah
yeah head transplant but they can't
connect nerves or anything like that
he was saying he was getting real close
to being able to do that which is
he was failing
yeah so there's definitely a lot of
really ghoulish things probably
happening within the
political system what about americans if
a rich american went there
had money would they be alike whatever
you say sir right away
here's your kidney good sir i'm sure in
principle i
like i have no specific uh there are
some countries that have outlawed
organ tourism to china because like
israel was one of the first countries to
do it actually
uh south korea has now taiwan has i
think these are there was a lot of
tourism coming from like south korea and
taiwan you know
asia so like one but once like
this started to become known and then
like
doctors in those regions started
speaking up and being like we should not
do this
but like it's still a very under the
radar
issue in general has the world always
been this way
or are we just in every possible
conceivable iteration of a dystopian
nightmare
book burning censorship zealotry
communism
organ harvesting organ tourism it's like
all of these stories not just here in
the us but around the world and it's
like
it's like every single nightmarish
dystopian novel has come
into existence at the exact same time or
around the same time
it does make you think like it's always
been this way
well it's it's it just shows like an
inability for
people as a whole to really stand up to
these kinds of things or in
very very often what happens is they get
manipulated
by those in charge to go along with
these kinds of things to go along with
the censorship the book burning
the killing of you know the group the
bad group that's hurting society
it's very easy to be manipulated
that's that's the crazy thing too about
like in the us not to derail too much
off of
china's internal problems but you know
they claimed trump was demonizing
migrants and muslims
well they were demonizing american
citizens you know that
so we we do see regardless of which
faction is trying to gain power
demagoguery and attacking a specific
group
seems to be the strong path to power
well it's since you mentioned that like
xi jinping
recently said the the us is the biggest
threat to
china's development and imagine if biden
said that about china
or any u.s official i mean i think trump
said things
similar to that right he got a little
close but biden's going to be
like come on man you know china's
they're helping us out they're good
people you know he's a master diplomat
yeah indeed yes well so let me let me
pull this story up here and then
we'll talk about u.s and china axios
reports americans
increasingly see china as an enemy
overall
55 view america as a competitor so you
were right earlier i was wrong you
mentioned it was about 34
viewed it's an enemy among republicans
53 view china as an enemy
and only 20 of democrats but it's about
a third of americans
see china as an enemy perhaps not uh
not enough for any real conflict but at
least in that regard with china now
demonizing the united states
i wonder if this is a step towards a
potential military conflict
i don't know where you guys your views
are right now between that
that scenario happening well
so for for a point of context um the
situation in hong kong
uh the chinese communist party has been
very successful at uh completely
annihilating any trace of democracy in
hong kong
uh once hong kong is taken care of to
the communist party's
satisfaction the next goal
is taiwan and that is something that
will draw
in the entire world the u.s
has made obligations to uh defend taiwan
in the event of any kind of
invasion um and taiwan is a very
strategic location
in the region so sooner or later we are
going to see taiwan become a flashpoint
uh but is biden going to actually
protect taiwan
well i uh i don't know
well he so he was the the first
president to have uh
essentially what the is the taiwanese
ambassador it's not
they're not called an ambassador because
of the one china whatever
yeah uh but he was the first president
to have this taiwanese representative
come to the inauguration
he has carried on uh freedom of
navigation operations in the south china
sea and in the taiwan strait
uh so he's done all of those things we
just
he hasn't explained what his china
policy is
so in many ways the the blind
administration has said
many of the right things but they
haven't
done much yet yeah and it is six weeks
six weeks right right right and even the
trump administration it took
it took a while for that
administration's china policy to kind of
crystallize
um for a variety of reasons you know
looking at
the uh us migrant crisis that's
happening right now and
and i'm not assuming you guys know a lot
about it but joe biden is getting a lot
of criticism from the left and the right
it's it's typically being seen as a
dramatic failure by
all by both political parties obviously
there are establishment democrats who
are supportive of joe biden
republican party trump populist types
they're super critical and left
populists are looking at joe biden as
though he's failing miserably in this
regard
because he's not really getting anything
done he's not helping the migrants in a
capacity where they'll be able to come
in here and get health care and get
access
well they're kind of coming in and being
released it's not all that great some
are being deported but then the trump
supporters see it as he's not doing
anything to stop it
i only bring that up because i have to
wonder if that's something that we
really can see and understand as
americans we we understand the border
we understand the arguments made around
it is that a sign of joe biden's
leadership on other issues as well which
may
you know reflect on what could happen
with china well i think from things that
have been said and again this is things
have been said and not done
they talk about uh diplomacy cooperating
with china
uh china might be a rival or a
competitor but you know we need to
cooperate with them
on climate change cetera et cetera but
the fundamental issue is when you look
at the chinese communist party as a
regime that is committing
genocide and that as we can see in the
case of hong kong lies
about any promise it makes how can you
cooperate how can you be diplomatic with
this kind of monstrous authoritarian
regime
so it blows the fundamental premise of
what he's said yeah and the water
i think the danger for the u.s and the
binding administration here is that
they are going to want to differentiate
differentiate themselves so much from
the trump administration
that like they they have to be like well
we are going to be diplomats we're going
to talk about diplomacy we're going to
talk about cooperation
this whole line about china being a
rival but we have to still cooperate on
shared
goals is one that's consistently been
said by like every biden
nominee that's gone up in front of like
senate hearings or whatever so
you have to say this is the line from
the biden administration the problem is
that's not what the chinese communist
party means by cooperate
the the word in chinese it just kind of
means like exchange
in any way so it could be just like you
know the cooperation doesn't it doesn't
mean like we're going to both work
together on climate change
it means if you want me to do something
about climate change
uh yeah what are you going to give up
like what are you going to give me
i don't think they're going to do
anything i think i think it's
duplicitousness oh yeah they're gonna
they're gonna say don't worry america we
got you you you give us the billion
dollars and then we'll get right on it
thank you for the bill and then what
billion dollars well the promise was in
four decades we'll be carbon neutral
yeah building more coal-fired power
plants
mean we've seen we've seen challenges
with cooperating with the chinese
communist party in the past
if you look at the george w bush
administration uh
they initially took us a tough stance on
the communist party but after 9 11
they're like well we have to work with
the communist party on fighting the
biggest threat which is the time was
terrorism and so the idea is we're going
to work with china
to fight global terrorism and what did
china do they didn't
cooperate towards america's goals on
fighting terrorism
they basically used as an excuse to go
after
their chinese muslims like the uyghurs
right
uh the obama administration then said oh
we have to cooperate with
china on climate change and you know
what what happened while china
signed you know the paris uh agreement
but
but ultimately what the china actually
do was
build a huge number of coal-fired power
plants releasing massive amounts of
carbon they ramped up their carbon
emissions
while using the excuse of being a
developing company country
but on top of that they also stole
the renewable energy technology from u.s
companies wind
power technology and solar technology
and now if you want to buy
a solar panel uh in america
you're basically buying one that's made
in china from
knocked off american technology and
that's how the communist party
cooperates on climate change
it's also uh powered by coal right right
so when they build those
you know you're you're ragging on china
coming down real hard over the the
burning of this carbon and all that
stuff
but they did build that big tv thing
right that showed the sunrise
oh i know that yeah yeah there's all the
smog in the air you've got to give them
credit for at least giving people
a glimmer of hope right it can't just be
a dreary post-apocalyptic smog
ping promised he's going to transform
china into a moderately prosperous
society
i i got to say i think uh i i feel like
the us is already lost
you know i think we're we're in a
propaganda war and information war and
economic war
and we are i i don't think the physical
confrontation matters as much
if it comes to a point where taiwan
knows the u.s has become too weak to
actually defend it
and their option is allowed china to
come in or die
i mean i feel like they might just be
like well we've got no defense anymore
we've got no leverage that's it we're
china now
it's hard to say because they know what
what it would mean for taiwan
is they become the next hong kong and
hong kong is looking more and more
a little less like shanghai and a little
more like xinjiang that was a point you
made the other day where it's it's very
what does that mean it means like it's
basically
like when the chinese communist party is
turning hong kong into another chinese
city they're not turning it into like
shanghai or beijing like
one of their cities they're turning into
xinjiang which is basically an open-air
prison
right like there was like all the
crackdowns in hong kong now like they're
basically going to
uh essentially strip out all the
democracy that existed
like no more being able to vote for
people uh in the legislature
like it's just they're completely
dismantling it and
there's maybe a bill that's going to
come up in front of the legislature that
is
now completely controlled by probating
officials
uh that would allow the hong kong
government to stop people from leaving
hong kong
wow like so that then it really does
become like a giant prison and there is
no prominent hong kong activist that is
they're all either in jail or in exile
at this point yeah and a lot of people
we had interviewed in hong kong just
a year and a half ago are in jail now
wow
yeah so really what happens in taiwan
will determine
whatever happens with the next but i
mean you look at you look at these
american companies that's why i say it
that was it lebron james who came out
and defended
china and then you had was it steve kerr
i think it was
well we don't talk about black lives
matter or you know or they don't talk
about
so we're not going to talk about what's
going on over there and it's like dude
they're the concentration camps like
it's a it's a big difference you got and
the nba has a training camp in shenzhen
and disney thanks yeah we talked about
all these industries they make so much
more money there
you go you got to look at who who owns
these big companies and their access to
wealth
american companies i i shouldn't even
call them american companies necessarily
they're multinational corporations at
this point
and the people in charge of them are
like i'm rich
i can do whatever i want and no one will
stop me why would i care about anybody
else
i mean blackrock has this whole web page
about
unleashing the potential of chinese
bonds
like yes what does that mean it means
like invest your money in china
yeah pump up the regime yeah you'll
invest your money in china
you'll get back a good return and you
will sell out everyone else into
serfdom or slave labor if china takes
taiwan
uh china becomes a superpower it's no
longer
the u.s is more powerful it's it would
be a tremendous
loss for this democracy yeah this is
what uh
xi jinping was saying about the you know
west is in decline
the east is rising yeah i mean it's true
yeah so that's
uh that's but at the same time saying
that the us is the biggest threat
to china so um more like
the us is the dominant power around the
world and it's who needs to be displaced
if china has to take over
what about the eu they'll stand up my
understanding is that the goal of the
european union was to compete with china
because they saw
you know how quickly it was rising and
they needed some kind of united force
they're not succeeding at that no
they're not that that's yes
uh and that has to do with uh the the
manufacturing and corporate power of
germany in particular
uh being very interested in developing
relationships
with china angela merkel has been very
supportive of that
uh and they volkswagen went into china
in like 1978 or 79
like the first western company to go
into china volkswagen has a
bad history well all of these companies
that go into china they
they they create a chinese communist
division within the company
for the communist party so if you have
50 or more employees
then you're required by chinese law to
have a party branch within your company
and this applies not just to chinese
companies but also to foreign companies
foreign companies also have to work
with a chinese company yeah so so yeah
they need a partner uh and until
recently it had to be a majority
uh partner 51 majority uh and so
essentially the foreign company can
operate but
there are certain things that they can
and can't do according to the party
whims and the party is
is in there with every major decision so
yeah like
mcdonald's having a party branch in
china does like it's hard to understand
like what that would really mean
but when it comes to like volkswagen so
their party branch is going to help
arrange things like
uh cheap labor for example or nike
you know we'll have a party branch and
maybe there's there's certain political
things that nike can't say
and there's also possibly the help that
they give for you know you get very
cheap labor from uh from uighurs who
don't have much choice well this is why
nike was
fighting against a uh forced labor bill
that would have
potentially gotten them trouble for
using forced labor and xinjiang
not that uh they were directly using it
but because of the web of how many of
like you know you saw
something from this person who sorts
something from this company down the
line and then somewhere along the line
there's weaker slave labor i mean it was
so easy and cheap so they decided to
just do it
it's not just weaker slave labor there's
a lot of prison labor like there's just
like
a lot of uh you know kind of dissident
prison labor
it's not just the uyghurs it's just that
the weakers are the biggest population
right it's a very visible in a way
they're an ethnic minority so you can
kind of tell who they are
in one region right too versus just like
well like so the issue with falun gong
was they were just anybody
they're just people who do the qigong
practice and so they blended in they
weren't like in one location so you
couldn't like see
like oh this is the specific
concentration camp where they're putting
them
right so this sounds horrible
yeah we do not want the chinese
communist party as a superpower leading
the world i don't think we can do
anything i think
is it pessimistic to say it's over what
do you guys think uh i think it is
pessimistic uh there has been you know
we all know the trump administration was
a bit controversial
china was one of the few bipartisan
issues um
i i i would imagine the bind
administration says it's reviewing the
trump administration designation of
what's happening to the uyghurs as
genocide i can't imagine it would be
politically feasible for
biden to come out and say well you know
it maybe it isn't genocide i just can't
imagine
what happened he came out and said well
you know there are cultural differences
in china
what he said was wrong for many reasons
not quite that he has been clear about
uh
condemning uh what the treatment of of
the uyghurs
i don't think he'll use the word
genocide personally not yet
because like it's just like how the
canadian parliament recently
voted that it was genocide but trudeau
and his entire cabinet
basically just didn't show up for the
vote yeah because
they were like the government abstains
like
i can i can't i can actually understand
and respect why
joe biden would not do that because he
needs to go in and be able to have some
kind of relationship
to actually have influence in a certain
capacity however while i can understand
that and same is true for trump when he
would go negotiate
why is he talking to kim jong-un or
whatever like well what he's going to do
throw a bomb first
it's at a certain point there's a line
we got to figure out how we stop these
things
i mean the the gulags in in north korea
are nightmarish
and the and the genes the genocide and
the concentration camps in in
china are probably the worst possible
thing
you know we could imagine existing in
terms of what a human could do to
another human
how do we stop it if we don't have a
president who's willing to say
that's the line the line is shouldn't
the line for i don't care if it's trump
or biden be
literal genocide he should say it
shouldn't trudeau say it
well as you say that's it prevents them
from having any kind of
diplomacy quote unquote yeah but but
the way i see it is when you when you
enter into genocide
yeah is diplomacy really soft diplomacy
i mean you could still have diplomacy to
a certain degree
you could have i'm gonna you know where
we're sanctioning you
we're making demands you end this now or
else
because this is a red line but we we
have these we have trudeau and binding
who are like well now hold on there you
know
yeah you need to have red lines that
there are consequences for crossing
those red lines and i think we had all
the red lines with syria
yeah well i think with the genus this is
why genocide is such a touchy issue
it's if western democracies and now the
dutch parliament has come out and also
called it a genocide
if they actually start using the word
genocide then it becomes a lot harder
for
not just like leaders of countries to
just act like china's normal country but
also
you know wall street for businesses
because really
the thing that we can do to stop china
is to cut off the money
yeah that is why they won't do it yeah
you have all these special interests
like i would mention the nba
you had blizzard the hearthstone thing
with free hong kong yeah
well that's free hong kong's long since
passed i suppose
there were there's there's an
opportunity each and every step of the
way for companies to say no
to china and they don't do it no i think
that's where
it has to be like when we were talking
about how people
now see more and more people see china's
enemy or
like like some kind of threat like it
has to be people who it has to be so bad
for these companies in the us
to not cut off that source of money in
china or whatever that they are willing
to do it like
if if the if the alternative is they
really like with google and dragonfly
like
it's such a bad thing for them that they
actually have to stop
like that's that's where we have to go
that was uh employee revolt wasn't it
yeah yeah
employees at google said no to the you
know dragonfly the dragonfly was out
yeah and good on them and i wish
employees at nike and the nba would
i mean if if you had you know if you had
a bunch of nba star like
real stars who said you know uh
we got to condemn what's happening there
then there
there'd be enough public pressure that
there there couldn't be much the nba
would do lebron james needs to call out
genocide right and and you know it's
it's fine
like i have no problem with with
basketball players using their
fame to talk about political issues in
the u.s what's happening in china
uh is so bad that like if you even talk
about it in china you get
arrested uh so you know you can't
criticize your own government inside
china
it's a very different situation but i
think the the overall
looking at um why is the chinese
communist party so powerful and have
they gotten so much power in the last 20
years
it's all because of foreign investment
it's partly just the money directly like
investing
in chinese bonds investing in chinese
companies and that sort of thing
but it's also the foreign companies
coming in giving their technology
allowing chinese companies to learn from
and even
steal a lot of this technology and help
compete these industries and then it's
us buying
those knockoff products back here in the
us so
that whole economic system is the
fundamental
core of that is foreign companies
especially u.s companies engaging in
that market
so to to the degree that you can cut off
the
the foreign company or american company
interaction
with china that's the degree to which
we're going to be able to rein in
that authoritarian power and we have to
focus there
but it's it's clear that even you know
even the trump administration which
which seemed to really want to do it was
was unable to achieve a whole lot with
that
um well it's going to take a lot a lot
more
google dragonfly situations where people
working here
who have that power as employees the
empower
citizens and his media to say we're not
going to tolerate
our companies working with a genocide
dictatorship
also you know consumers not buying
products made in china
don't go to an nba game yeah like it has
to the other thing that
the us government could do was what the
trump administration started doing like
actually
putting chinese companies that work with
chinese military on
entity lists like blacklisting them so
getting them de-listed from the stock
yeah so soon there are going to be a big
bunch of big chinese companies that
can't trade on wall street anymore but
is joe biden going to keep those
policies going
i don't know we don't know he hasn't
said i kind of feel like he's uh
he wouldn't do that like you mentioned
before you know he's going to try and
differentiate himself from the trump
administration
so already you know we had this uh this
trump put in this executive order about
keeping china out chinese made you know
equipment
out of the u.s u.s electrical grid and
then joe biden's like we're gonna freeze
that rule
so it's no longer an effect and review
it and i'm like if you want to review
the rule
wouldn't you leave the the restrictions
in place
why would joe biden just say okay yeah
china come back into the u.s electrical
grid
i think it's a little unclear what
happened and like he could potentially
be using that
for his advantage but there was sort of
a blanket freeze on a lot of last
minute uh right policies by trump which
i think is in general
pretty common for an incoming president
to do
uh and the issue is with biden like so
that could be i'm so fine he's he's
frozen those he reviews him
the issue with the biden administration
is it comes under this cloud
of uh biden personally and a lot of the
people he's appointed to his cabinet
they're past
failures with china policy uh
scandals like hunter biden putting this
cloud overbite and gives him the
appearance of
like you should not be questioning if
the u.s president is really going to
condemn
genocide yeah and we are and the other
thing too is i think it's fascinating
how
they say that you know donald trump was
the manchurian candidate for russia or
whatever that he was a russian asset he
was a puppet or
or you know and all that stuff and now
we actually have the circumstance where
you know we're six weeks out and joe
biden has not
given an address to a joint session of
congress
you'd have to go back to jimmy carter in
1977 for the for the last time it took
this long now he was into april so maybe
joe biden will
still beat jimmy carter and give some
kind of speech but he's not given a
press conference
in in in the entirety of his his six
weeks so
already things seem to be a bit
unprecedented and then we had that
scenario where he was giving
uh he was talking to the democratic
caucus and then he says i'll take
questions
the camera shuts off the feed ends
now many people on the right said as
soon as joe biden offered to take
questions they turned the camera off and
the response from the journalists was
he took the questions off camera you're
misunderstanding you're confused and my
response is
why why was he doing the session live
and then took the cam the questions off
camera that's a ridiculous excuse
because either way the american people
deserve to see
what our politicians are asking the
president and what he is saying to them
when i saw that you know i was sitting
at jack murphy and he was jack was just
like
manchurian candidate like not literally
just like kind of joking like
what's going on to where the president
of the united states
isn't doing press conferences isn't
giving a joint uh
an address to the joint session of
congress and then he can't even answer
questions on a live stream
who is he what's he doing and then you
tie that into the hunter biden stuff
flying his son in air force two to china
for that private equity deal
and then am i supposed to trust this
president has our best interest
at heart as we're entering either
the strass howe generational theory
winter
or thucydides trap there there's
academics who are
telling us we're in for some serious
trouble and we're looking at genocide
and we're looking at organ harvesting
and we're looking at hong kong falling
now we're looking at taiwan
it looks like china is getting away with
every single
thing they've done wrong and we're doing
nothing about it but say what maybe some
sanctions here and there
well i think that 2020 was actually a
banner year for the chinese communist
party it didn't start out that way it
looked like the world was going to turn
against them after the coronavirus it's
amazing they
they turned they turned out that
completely around and
now they're using that as propaganda for
like how well that their system is doing
compared to everybody else
more reason to cooperate with china and
i think that like
one the one thing the biden
administration recently came out with
their interim national security policy
and reading that i was actually pretty
worried about how they were going to
like deal with china because it seemed
to kind of revert back to like an
obama administration era of like the
whole thing that we were talking about
before about like we need to cooperate
still
um the trump administration specifically
in their national security policy
called out the chinese communist party
and said you know it's a marxist
leninist organization
said we we are going to treat this the
way that the chinese communist party
treats this which is
which they said that they are in a great
power competition with the us
so fine we acknowledge that you know
china says that we're in a great power
competition with them
and the administration seems to have
gone back to
that like oh you know we disagree we're
economic rivals we're competitors but
we can work together on some things and
then the other part of the national
security policy that i found kind of
a little bit alarming is the fact that
they seem to want to blur the line
between
foreign policy and domestic policy like
there's a specific part where they talk
about
how you know we can't just have foreign
policy and domestic policy be separate
we have to
you know if we really want to have
effective foreign policy we have to fix
our own internal problems
so then that brought up like systemic
racism and equity and all this stuff
so it seems like if that's what they
want to focus on
they're going to be too focused on like
internal things and
this ideological battle and not focused
enough on
the genuine threat that the chinese
communist party is which is strange
because
the executive branch their main thing is
to deal with foreign policy domestic
policy is supposed to be
the legislative branch well here we are
with uh every single uh
line item of china violating some kind
of human rights
civil rights stealing destroying we're
buying back
around technology that was stolen from
us and then cheaply
knocked off and built by slaves built by
slaves and they just keep doing it and
we just keep you know doting along
accepting it i will say
i posted a meme though that was that was
uh made everybody angry
it was on i think it was in the 20th i
said uh the peaceful transition of power
from the previous administration
to the new administration is complete
and it was a picture of vladimir putin
and then
xi jinping and i was like there you go
whatever your political ideology is you
know the left viewed trump as this like
beholden guy to russia but russia wasn't
really doing all that much
i mean sure there's conflict over
pipelines and you know
ukraine and things like that syria
perhaps
but what's happening with china really
does seem to be
it could be theoretically the catalyst
for some very serious major war if we're
not already in the peak of it which is
information war
but you know i i that's why i have to
wonder about the things we see in
america in the culture war
is it really in the best interest of
either america or china to engage a hot
war with missiles and bullets probably
not it never is for anybody it's very
expensive and then you have to hope
you're going to win
but information warts it's more syrup
tissues it's aversive
so i wonder you know to what extent
china is
influencing our social media and
manipulating us much the way they
accused
the russians of doing it i don't know if
you guys have seen anything that would
suggest
those kind of operations i think it's a
little different actually what china has
really been
manipulating very successfully isn't
american elites
and it's almost like they don't have to
do the kind of awkward like twitter
thing right where they're like
having dummy accounts on twitter and
trying to influence people on facebook
like the chinese companies probably much
better at this than i mean russia
they just tweeted out right like the the
members of the chinese communist party
are like tweeting really offensive
things
like the picture of the australian
soldier or whatever they just it's it's
it's uh
reminds him that simpson simpson's a bit
i don't know if you guys have ever seen
the episode
where bart joins a boy band that's
subliminally trying to get people to
join the navy
and the art the navy recruiter tells
lisa we
we recruit by the subliminal the liminal
and the super liminal
and lisa goes super liminal and he goes
yeah and he opens the window and goes
hey you
join the navy and then lenny and carl
are like okay
so so that's kind of what i feel like
when i see these like high rank you know
these like
you know uh officials in the communist
party or like chinese government
officials
blue check mark on twitter tweeting some
ridiculous absurd conspiracy theory
about the election or the president and
it's allowed they're allowed they're
allowed to do it i'm like there it is
that's
that's the super liminal right in your
face we're lying
and we can do whatever we want we don't
need bots i well so a good example of
this
is um how china manipulates language man
i'm going to pass that
off to you in just a second but like
just like one example of how chinese
propaganda seeps
into uh american discourse is
going back to the biden town hall how he
was talking about how
john you know china had the century of
humiliation they need they
need to have the strong centralized core
that's communist party propaganda that's
being parroted
by president by the president and that's
not like
that's not saying he's not unique in
that it's because the communist party is
very good at
uh taking language and changing the
meaning of it
yeah i mean i think it's it's not just
just that which i get to in
a minute but the the you'll circle back
to that yeah
the overall idea is like you know you
tim you talk about the
the overt stuff uh the super liminal
we're seeing on twitter which is the
propaganda from the chinese foreign
minister but the
the real way that we're seeing that
influence is actually through what's
called elite capture
which is the chinese communist party
convincing
influential people around the world
including
american politicians american business
leaders american academics
these are the and and journalists these
are the thought leaders in american
society
and the communist party is is
influencing them
and now these groups the the politicians
the
business leaders the media are all
the cheerleaders for the communist party
and
it may not be so obvious that they're
saying rah-rah-rah communism because
they're not saying it that way
what they're saying is like well look at
uh you know china has lifted millions of
people out of poverty
uh but you know china uh you know china
is a competitor but we need to work with
them
and they've gotten people to to parrot
these lines which
on the surface seem reasonable but
actually they're exactly what the
communist party wants and they do that
through a variety of influence campaigns
to get these people on their side the
challenge is
like when we hear um you know
whether it's uh you know bernie sanders
saying oh you know
but you know china i don't like
authoritarianism but china has
lifted 700 million people out of poverty
right
well it it's that's the propaganda line
that's making you think well maybe they
do have some elements to their system
that work because look how many people
they've lifted out of poverty
and it is true that since 1978
hundreds of millions of people in china
have
gotten out of poverty but it's not the
communist party that
lifted them out of poverty it was the
communist party that
put them in poverty in the first place
ah yeah right but then how did they get
out of poverty it wasn't government
policy was it was actually
the reform and opening up the gaiga
kaifung started by deng xiaoping in 78
and these policies gradually took the
boot off of people's necks
so that they could you know have
businesses and and start their own
uh enterprises in the free market and
people lifted themselves out of poverty
and investment it's kind of like when
it's you know in the summer and it's
really hot
and you're really sweaty so you go under
the blanket for a few seconds
and then you get really hot when you
take the blanket off it feels really
cool and refreshing
for a little bit yeah so so maybe what
we should do in the us
is have this uh extended lockdown where
we destroy
everyone's business for maybe a year and
then
after about you know two years because
you know biden saying
next year is normal then we can be like
look at all of the people the biden
administration has lifted out of poverty
he's
tremendously starting with the bankers
yes which i mean oh they came in real
quick to save those folks
uh and you know i mean there's nothing
i'm not saying there's anything you know
necessarily wrong about trying to keep
the stock market from having a complete
crash
but uh definitely
uh there are some shortcomings in terms
of the overall response
but anyway to to get to the point about
like
uh you've got you've got the communist
party getting people to repeat these
lines
but the problem is you know when when
you hear this you know
lifting millions of people out of
poverty you also have to realize
like that china now says for example uh
you know being out of poverty is a human
right
right so that it's the top human rights
it's the main sounds like
it's the main human right and and so
like a lot of people on the surface they
think oh
well like yeah like like it's so bad to
be in this abject poverty like maybe
maybe it is a human right to to have
money and
you know you can agree or disagree on
that but that's not the point
the point is that now you know you've
added
uh the communist party has added
economic prosperity
as a human right uh and they've gotten a
lot of people to kind of go along with
it but what you're not seeing is that
they've
they haven't just added on to the
meaning of human rights they've actually
changed the meaning
because china is using that
instead of giving people the human
rights that we consider human rights the
life the rights to life
liberty in the pursuit of happiness you
don't have the right to life when you
can be sent to
a concentration camp or killed for your
organs
or welded into your apartment so you can
die
yeah i mean and that's like the the fact
that that's happening
in china as part of their coveted
response shows a complete disregard
for human rights a complete disregard
for individual liberty liberties
uh but you got a macbook yeah well i
mean
well and then china says out but we
stopped kovit yeah we had to weld people
in their homes but we
stopped because which isn't true the
giant bar
they like wedged between the door and
the wall so the door can't be opened
there's one of like a woman being
dragged into like this
box on a pickup truck screaming the
whole time yeah well i think the other
thing with the
the the elite capture is like you
one thing that it's important to notice
and i think we'll see more and more of
this is you'll see
people saying we need to re-engage with
china there was a foreign affairs
magazine
article by this guy named ryan haas that
was basically
saying you know china alarmism doesn't
help anyone
like that was basically the title sounds
like mark cuban right yeah like yeah
this whole idea that like oh we can't
you know that mark cuban definitely the
whole like china's a customer so we
can't really critic i don't want to
criticize them because they're a
customer
but like this whole idea uh that like we
need to like re-engage like oh
the trump administration was wrong too
like you know they made the conflict
worse
when really it was really the chinese
communist party but
the whole idea is that we need to now
like we need to soften our stance to
china china's not so bad the communist
party is not so bad
you know yeah i mean it's just a little
genocide you want to talk about that
atrocious
uh economist article oh yeah there was
an article on the economist
after the whole um genocide thing with
the trump administration and they said
okay uh the the canadian parliament was
voting that was genocide and the
economist ran this article
basically being like is it really
genocide though
because you know when people even though
the un definition of genocide includes
trying to eliminate a people uh
including
by preventing births and sterilization
and things that are happening to the
uyghurs in china like that is part of
the un convention on genocide
like that is def defined as genocide the
economist was like but most people think
of genocide as being mass murder
so if it's not to that point yet and we
use the word genocide aren't we kind of
you know isn't that worse for you know
future genocides that like
now cheapen the word specifically said
they're not slaughtering them
as they're being butchered their own
well no the organ harvesting is just
win-win mutual cooperation cooperation
on the communist party's terms between
the uyghurs and the don't and the organ
recipients yes that's cooperative
there's an exchange going on so it's
cooperation
as long as two parties are willing in
this it doesn't matter
yeah someone else isn't i mean it's it's
a democracy so it's for the the good of
the majority yes the
what do they say the people's
dictatorships well if they don't view
the uyghurs as people then there's no
as humans there's no human rights
violation right oh no the
the 56 ethnic minorities of china are
very happy
every year they have a wonderful new
year's show where they they bring
them all out and have a little dance
number or they'll give the bbc a guided
tour of these
alleged concentration camps and they're
singing and
getting you know job skills and they're
dancing for the camera
with bruises over their eyes like it's
very
it is but it's very hard for foreigners
to see what's actually happening in
china
i think you have to bring it down yeah
like like you can't like you just don't
get access as a foreigner
like the the last time i was in mainland
uh
which was which was more than 15 years
ago it's you know
uh it wasn't even so closed off but at
the time
like you know they wanted foreigners to
be in certain parts
of the big cities uh and they wanted you
to be on
on tours and they didn't want you to go
outside of that
and if they did and if you did go
outside of that the authorities might
try to like
you know get you to go back to your
hotel uh and now it's even more
restrictive
uh where like they're basically they
keep journalists out of going to like
villages where controversial things are
going on they you know essentially a
foreign reporter can't possibly get into
to better xinjiang anymore
so yeah it's it's just like like the
people who are going to china these
the politicians the business people the
academics
they're going to the cities they're
getting on these high-speed rails
they're staying in the five-star hotels
they're eating at nice restaurants and
this is the part of china they see
and so they have a very skewed
view of what china is
okay well so here's here's a bit of
optimism for you you're saying you're
pessimistic
um yeah that's absolutely right it's
hard for foreigners to know what's
happening in china
the reason i started china and censored
in 2012 was because
everything we've talked about tonight is
really not new it's been going on
for decades i started the show because
americans didn't know about it americans
weren't talking about this and just
thought china was like oh you know
developing country it's a democracy
right so now you talk
there's a president but now you talk
about this pew
research uh and the it's totally
shifted people are talking about the
chinese communist party in a way they
were not
yeah even eight years ago even five
years ago it's interesting the president
thing because i have had
multiple conversations with friends of
mine who were like
didn't know that china didn't have
democracy because the it's called
he called them president xi jinping even
though the word in chinese
is not president it is chairman chairman
of the state right so
like the word they use in chinese to
talk about xi jinping there's a
different word that they use for
president that they used to talk about
biden
or you know like it's like the word is
zongtong
why do we call them presidents
propaganda because they started
translating in the 80s they started
translating
president that drew c which is chairman
as president like officially the
official translation
in china in china and so manipulation
yeah so that that's the they twist the
language wow another
example um i want you to tell the story
uh about the uh the struggle
xi jinping in the struggle yeah so uh xi
jinping recently gave it a
uh speech to young chinese communist
party members where he told them you
know
you know you have to like really believe
in the party and carry on the strong
traditions and spirit of the party
and the chinese language in the english
uh state-run media reports it was like
oh yeah and he was inspiring them to
talk about you know how great the party
is and serve the people
in chinese there was a like the term
that they he kept bringing up was the
term struggle which is dojung
which is a marxist leninist like chinese
communist party idea of
using the dialectic right like two
opposing sides and then they have to
struggle
and like one has to win against so it's
like oppressed versus oppressor
or you know proletariat versus
bourgeoisie whatever
so it's like in uh china like the
chinese communist party will
have you know in the cultural revolution
you had to do jung against the
counter revolutionaries like this idea
of struggling against
an opposing side so in chinese xi
jinping said struggle
the whole time during the thing like we
have to young communist party members
must remember
this to struggle the communist party is
like tradition of struggle all this
stuff
completely wiped out in english because
they don't want
uh to make the communist party look like
that so we look back at history we know
the culture revolution
the cultural revolution was horrifying
struggle sessions and all that stuff
what was before communist china was was
it also an oppressive system was it was
the government
you know horrible to its people well
people kind of mistakenly talk about
chinese history like it was it's
monolithic thing
when in fact it was in very diverse over
[Music]
thousands of years uh and there were
definitely
times where the society was more
prosperous and stable there was times
where it's more oppressive
um like even like we started talking
about like uh
the masculinity thing and like in a lot
of articles i was reading about that
uh the sort of western take on that was
well you know in in china they believe
that you know
young masculine is strong and you know
yin
is weak and women again is women and
should be
weak and submissive and that's not
that's not even really accurate that's a
complete misunderstanding
of uh these
ancient chinese principles like yin and
yang are supposed to be in balance
in many martial arts there's there they
say
and taoism says the soft overcomes the
heart so soft
yin does not mean weak right
um so golly what was i trying to say
well i was asking
the government before the communist
party was it oppressive well i mean
which government right like which of
the media is immediately immediately
proceeding so the republican
period is that what it was it was it was
horribly corrupt
um it also was dealing with world war ii
and fighting japanese
right and fighting communist conversion
i mean this this year marks a hundred
years since the formation
of the chinese communist party in 1921
which was
uh connected to the soviets which the
soviets had tried to
you know start the the com that was the
third uh the third
communist international the common turn
and get that branch going in china
because at the time the idea of the
soviets was we're gonna
have communism spread around the world
so they were starting all these party
cells
so so the the qing dynasty
fell 1911 11.
and then it was followed by you know a
little bit of chaos and then
the republic of china came up but within
you know a decade
you had the communist party starting and
essentially
sowing chaos throughout the country to
the to the degree that they were able to
uh sometimes working with the republic
of china government sometimes
fighting against them but always even
when working when they were subverting
it from within
yeah and so there was no real chance for
the republic of china government to
be a fully functioning government and it
was a very difficult time and i'm not
defending some of the things that
happened there because there were some
some challenges but it's the classic uh
communist party tactic of you know the
republican period of china it was
corrupt there were definitely issues
there was uh
wealth inequality so the communist party
uses that and said hey
these guys are oppressing you this
society's you know these are the bad
guys hey
then they and mao would go to the the
poor peasants in the countrysides and
promise them
a better future a more equal future now
the elites of that period
the ones who you know towed the party
line
were they spared oh i mean the biggest
victims of the communist party are
communist party members i mean even
before the communist party actually
ruled the country there were tons of
purges
within the party rectification that
basically meant uh thought control and
thought
reform and brainwashing that was kind of
where sort of one of the the first
sort of mass brainwashing campaigns in
history is the communist party
brainwashing and torturing other
communist party officials in a part of
china called yanan
like that that's how they treat their
own people
how do you think they're treating
everyone else i mean the guy who was
supposed to succeed mao
lin biao right oh died in a mysterious
plane
and then suddenly like he was like mal's
second in command then mysteriously died
and then suddenly like the word was oh
he was very bad he was
communicating the campaign to criticize
confucius in libya
it was like the mass political campaign
to criticize
like the political enemy so but if you
look at marxism right if you read
marx uh marx's view is that uh karl marx
not groucho marx
uh the view is that the history of
humanity is a history of class struggle
right and this is i believe an
inaccurate
view of humanity in history but that's
the marxist view
and that was the leninist view and
that's the was the maoist view and
that's the xi jinping view
so the idea is that uh there are always
these two opposing forces
that always have to fight and the only
way for history to progress
is through these groups struggling
against each other and so
the the communists uh they believe this
actually
uh and so they believe that they must
struggle against enemies
and if there's not an enemy if they've
defeated an enemy there must they need
to create another enemy
so there's always going to be an enemy
there's always going to be a persecuted
group
there's no there's no way for a
communist party to not have
a group that they're going after because
that is the way they see
their own society and powers moving
forward there has to always be class
structure which is why we as americans
should be very concerned with xi jinping
telling the new cadre to struggle
i mean on a foreign policy level that
the chinese communist party has to
struggle with the united states
which is the global hegemon right so
there's
always going to be that struggle do you
see uh parallels
between the cultural revolution and
what's happening today because you know
we that a lot of people call what's
happening with cancer culture struggle
sessions
well so it's it's this is something that
has been people have made that
comparison before and it's it creates a
lot of controversy because there
aren't roving bands of red guard killing
people
yet but i think they were like the red
guy they were literally murdering just
people in large numbers uh so the the
thing the quest the real question
is how does a society get to that point
what
breeds that uh and
so we do need to be vigilant because if
this happened once before
in human history it could happen again
well like how many people were the red
guard killing
uh numbers of people who died in the
cultural revolution it varies
probably maybe
15 to 20 like the high end is 20 million
as an as a
as a estimate of how many people died
during the cultural
revolution there was no period among
these revolutionaries where they knew
they were in the cultural revolution it
was only
with hindsight we looked back and then
said here's where it is the cultural
revolution was a specific campaign by
now okay
to eliminate the four olds which was old
thought old culture i forget all the old
ones
i just mean like was there a p was there
a point where mao was like okay today is
the day we start go
and kill people well he was like today
we must start the cultural revolution
to you know basically rectify the
culture of the party so there was an
actual like start date for that and it
ended when he died
and people were like after a really long
time yeah well it was like 10 decades
yeah
yeah it was it was i i remember speaking
to one chinese person who
was alive at the time and they said it
was basically we talk about like the 10
years that we went crazy
i mean it was really bad although in
some areas it was worse than others and
like by the
by the end mao was kind of like not
doing well so it was
it kind of petered out but like
literally you had to quote mao's little
red book to like be able to
buy food you know like you were like get
on a bus you had to say a quote from mao
yeah but like you know the
there are i understand why some people
see parallels with what's happening in
the us today
i think the there's a few big
differences in the and the chief one is
that
the u.s government protects freedom of
speech
and you know even if you get cancelled
on twitter and and
kicked off of youtube and you know your
books are banned from the publisher like
you're not going to be arrested you're
not going to be
there's no legal mechanism to send you
to prison
that's not that's not sure there is they
just lie
okay so but that's i mean i mean you
take a look at the the antifa riots
throughout the pacific northwest
we just learned there was an
investigation that found 31 of 90 had
their charges dropped and many dismissed
with prejudice
which according to one expert this is
extremely rare for them to actually do
this
some of these were felony charges where
antifa literally assaulted an officer
their charges are dropped now when it
comes to the the
out group which would be these you know
trump supporters at the capitol
you have the incidence of some people
this is really interesting cause i'm
seeing journalists say this the shaman
guy with the horns
apparently he argued in court the cops
waved him in
and it's on video the cops are waving
and people are following the cops waving
and the cops open the door
not everybody who went in the building
were shoving their way through police
and fighting with cops
there were many circumstances where the
doors were just opened up now i think
obviously everybody who went in the
building was dumb and it was a huge
mistake for these people
but you take a look at how after
you know six seven months of rioting and
cities being burned down
and these antifa people i mean the vice
president was soliciting donations to
bail her out
so we can say there's no legal mechanism
in a sense but there is a cultural
mechanism that guarantees
if you're far leftist and you burn down
a city
it is very likely that you will face no
cultural repercussions
or none whatsoever i mean they're not
being targeted by law enforcement as
terrorists
they're being the vice president's
raising money joe biden's own staffers
were raising money to get them out but
if you're a trump supporter
who was just in dc you're this woman
she's a psychological operations officer
in the army
she was simply attending a speech she's
been she's under investigation one guy
was a music a rapper he's an artist his
label dropped him for simply being
in dc when this happened so that's
what's scary to me
we can say oh but we have a constitution
sure but what happens when the federal
government
just lies and then you have the entirety
of the establishment democratic left
saying
good they want to do a commission on
these people now i think it's
it's you know maybe the fear is perhaps
a bit pessimistic
but maybe the fear is that they learn
from what these other countries did and
how to avoid
you know falling into certain traps they
don't want to kill people they want
control they don't want
to look like the villains themselves
especially in an age of social media and
instant transmission of information
so they use clever manipulation to make
sure their political dissidents are
stripped destroyed and removed
and that's what's happening i do think
that it is different in the us
like if the cultural revolution happened
in the u.s it could not happen the same
way that it happened in
china because we do not have uh like
it's not
we have guns well well besides that like
the whole mechanism is like started in
china by the state like it's started by
the chinese communist party it's like
top down but
also the cult of personality mao hat
which doesn't but
i think that like in the us the
mechanism is
like if you have these tech companies if
you have
like uh like the democratic party or
like you have
you have this like cultural mechanism
for it that is
like a different manifestation but it
could like the
psychologically there are similarities i
would say and especially in terms of
like things like the
you know reporting on people like the
like there are things that
that could happen with this cancel
culture stuff that's going on that could
follow like the course of the cultural
revolution without
being a thing that is done by the yeah
or done by the state exactly or like you
know but it could have like the same
you can have neighborhood watch
committees where you know or
you know everybody's looking at whatever
you know you're pulling up what you said
on twitter 20 years
perhaps we're just not at that stage of
what the cultural revolution was yet
but we do have you know just recently
the it was christopher wray
i believe it was fbi saying you know
domestic terror
coming you know i i don't know if he
specifically called out trump supporters
but i think he said you know far-right
domestic terrorists the biggest threat
we're facing
you've got the democrats saying trump
supporters and q anon
they're claiming that they need to keep
these troops surrounding dc with razor
wire fences
and these and the and you know razor
wire and these fences
because of the these conspiracy theories
about trump's true inauguration
you are getting from mainstream press a
narrative
over and over and over again of who the
evil is calling for
they're calling it the one six
commission they want a 911 style
commission on what happened at the
capitol they're acting like it was on
par with 911
and they're continually demonizing trump
supporters populist right-wingers
conservatives
to the point where you know we've
mentioned it several times now echelon
insights interviewed
democrats what is you know of these
things how would you rate your level of
concern
the top concern among democrats is trump
supporters
white nationalists white supremacy and
among trump supporters
among republicans it's illegal
immigration taxation support for the
police
very run-of-the-mill conservative
positions it seems like the narrative
we're getting from the mainstream press
about how bad and awful
the right is in this country is reaching
that level where
i mean people i think are ready to
person go insane so perhaps at the point
where you'll see red guard going around
literally murder murdering people
but we are getting danger to that point
where i believe it's entirely possible
you will see the democrats come out and
straight up say
arrest them all every single one because
we're already getting that point nicole
wallace on msnbc said
if they were in a different country
would have blown him up by now with a
drone strike
what wouldn't mitch mcconnell think
trump should be arrested for what he did
we have an article from the root where
they said republicans are enemy
combatants
that we must treat as enemy combatants
the route
in 2018 according to news whip was the
number one publication on the left
now the right got substantially more
engagements but they were still number
one
what happens when you have prominent
democratic uh politicians
people like ocasio-cortez saying ted
cruz you tried to get me
murdered and they're telling this to
people over and over again where do we
go in a year
perhaps right now we're saying oh but in
the cultural revolution they were
they were called upon by the by the
party by the by the political figures to
go and
and do these things and it's like okay
well maybe in a year they do that maybe
in two years three years
all i know is right now i'm constantly
being told by the press how
trump is an insurrectionist who tried to
overthrow the united states government
and youtube has deleted every iteration
of his speech from cpac
this level of tribalist demonization
isn't stopping it's escalating it's
getting worse
and it seems to me like we we are
dangerously close to this point where
the hysteria reaches this level perhaps
we have a president in joe biden
who he's already failing his first test
in the in the migrant crisis
the left is outraged over his migrant
detention centers for children
the right is outraged over his releasing
of covet positive patients covered
positive illegal immigrants into texas
as well as shutting down trump's border
wall so now you've got both sides angry
with him he didn't get the stimulus
checks out
are we potentially looking at a pathetic
and failed leader
who causes widespread you know just a
demoralization among even moderates in
this country that results
in donald trump running again in 2024
against the kamala harris who does not
have the charisma to win
trump ends up getting a decisive but
slim victory
and then you have all of that
conditioning over four years of the
demons of the insurrectionists
trump finally completed his interaction
he took the country over we must go we
must purge we must stop this
or perhaps it goes the other way trump
becomes president and says they're the
bad guys they're the ones trying to
subvert it
like the hyperpolarization is getting
just that scary to me
well democracy is very fragile and
you know you're mentioning the
commission making the comparison to 911
what's the lesson of 911 the government
used terrorism to create the patriot act
which
was really more about making the
government more powerful and taking away
the rights of
the american people i mean it's it's
about power and control and what you
kind of just described
was a struggle session essentially and
so this is where people need to
learn from history and see the patterns
are these actual threats
that are being discussed or is it just
somebody creating
that opposition that they need to have
the
dialectical conflict well that's it the
struggle right
there's something to struggle against
there's an interesting book that that
talks a lot about this sort of thing i
think you're talking about it's called
uh
how the specter of communism is ruling
the world
uh it makes some interesting points um
well people can read that themselves and
draw their conclusions but it looks at
history and you do see
you know there are people who learn from
all of these tactics that have been used
for control
and people who want control they're not
idiots they look at what has worked and
what hasn't worked and refined
the chinese communist party is a much
more refined
soviet union they're not making many of
the same mistakes the soviet union
did because they learned from them
that's why chinese comments party is
still here
yeah they constantly talk about
gorbachev and how nobody can be a
gorbachev basically
remember people thought she would be
gorbachev i remember there was an event
held in dc
a bunch of trump supporters were
protesting against massive multinational
billion dollar corporations
that were suppressing speech political
speech in the u.s
the trump supporters were protesting and
targeting
billionaires antifa shut up and
physically attacked them
it's it's interesting that you have this
demonization
for the populist right it's the elites
the establishment
for the populist left it's the populist
right and i wonder if that's just the
convenient tool of the establishment to
say
get these people to attack them because
they're attacking us
using this idea of the struggle this
this conflict between factions
to make sure nobody actually goes after
them if they keep doing that
well eventually using trump supporters
conservatives and populist right-wingers
as your scapegoat will result in
such extreme hyperpolarization that
people start getting killed we've
already seen
with the riots over last year i think
there was 19 official deaths caused by
the riots
and then there are i believe 11 or 12 uh
about 12
peripheral deaths just out in like as a
result of the rioting some people died
for certain reasons
but then we also had that uh that guy in
portland who took two in the chest from
that antifa guy
with the he had the black lives matter
tattoo on his neck the revolution fest
and he shot him twice in the chest when
you say riots you're talking about the
mostly peaceful protests
yes right yes where buildings were on
fire and destroyed and
over two billion dollars in in insurance
payouts
not even the total cost of damage that
we saw and uh
and the the vice president and president
supporting those actions
you know you want you wanna know
something absolutely insane
andrew cuomo this new report coming out
that
he his administration instructed the
health department
to obscure the amount of people who died
in nursing homes as a result of their
policies
on march 25th of last year cuomo he
announced this policy to send
covet patients into nursing homes
nursing homes
resisted saying this will introduce the
virus into the most vulnerable
populations
they said so what 15 000 people died
cuomo covered it up and that is
confirmed
one assemblyman has said it's a criminal
a coordinated criminal conspiracy
i've said send the guy to prison andrew
cuomo still enjoys a 65
approval rating and a 60 favorability
rating among democrats
when you have that level of he's been
accused of
harassing women three women have stepped
forward and even
prominent democratic uh like
left-leaning liberal-type figures in the
media are criticizing him saying
he should resign democrats are saying he
should resign
it is now being reported by mainstream
left right wing publications
he killed these people he covered it up
the democrat voter still favors him 65
so when you have things like that it
says to me like tribalism
owns everything you could have quite
literally when donald trump said i could
shoot somebody on fifth avenue
you want kitten that's a good point yeah
tribalism it's it's
it is a tool of dictators it's uh the
more
the less we see each other as fellow
humans
that actually have more in common than
we do differences
that gets easily used when we start to
just see
the other the enemy yeah well how about
we take super chats
we'll see what the audience has to say
if you haven't already smash
the like button and uh subscribe at the
notification bell
if you're listening on itunes spotify or
any other podcast platform leave us a
good review give us as many
stars as they allow and then write why
we're the best because it really does
help the show
and i guess the saying goes the only way
people find out about podcasts is from
people who listen to podcasts so if you
like it you just gotta share it
but uh again smash that like button and
let's read some of these super chats
so usually this happens if we have a
pinned bit of merchandise i can't see
the name of the person who gave us the
first super chat so i apologize but
they asked have you ever watched attack
on titan and if so do you see parallels
that it has with our reality have any of
you watched attack on titan
can't say it is like the most popular
anime
but uh no idea i've only seen a couple
episodes
all right let's see toby walker oh this
is very important important he says toy
boat toy boat toy boat
did you know there are 16 unique species
of penguins
toy boat toy boat toy boat unique new
york specific pacific
specific pacific toy boat toy boat
congratulations you got me to say those
things good for thought are you trying
to like do a defeat or something by
having me say all of that
unique new york jordan jones says i hope
that the team is doing well at tim cast
irl
at what point do states and individuals
stop sending resources to the federal
government
that is pushing radical left policies
that are hurting their well-being
i honestly have no idea i don't know
do you guys see any i i know your
specialty is more china
but uh perhaps that was just my opinion
thinking you know being more pessimistic
but
what's your what's your your prospect on
this country do you think optimism
pessimism
i i'm ultimately optimistic um
i gotta say after that last uh spiel of
yours
the optimism's a bit uh i have drained
the optimism from you
uh no i i mean i think ultimately
this was something they talked about in
ancient china people innately
are good well in ancient china they
didn't always agree with that either
but i think people there's an innate
goodness to them that they
want to they they value there are
universal values
that people have and i know that's not
something that's necessarily
people like to talk about universal
values anymore you know i can be both
pessimistic and optimistic at the same
time
in saying that i think the night is
always darkest before the dawn
and we have not read uh we have not yet
reached the uh the darkest point of the
night yet
so it seems like things are going to get
pretty bad but then maybe after
the tumult things will be a bit better
yeah i think people do need to
get a better better understanding of
some of the things that are happening
yeah that will take time
all right lua coder says i am distraught
that lots of our manufacturing industry
has moved over to china
even roblox i used to play playback in
2011 is opening their market to china
the checklist for ugc is absurd is there
any
grassroots lobbying that can be done to
bring our manufacturing back
interestingly the biden administration
is currently doing review of supply
chains
in the u.s so this is something that i
think democrats care a lot about and
republicans
uh from a national security standpoint
and from like a kind of
you know a worker's rights you know like
populist standpoint so
this might be one of those things where
we do start to bring back some of that
at least critical manufacturing like you
know drugs medical supplies
chuck schumer was talking about the
making some kind of
law to help us out compete china yeah so
i think a lot of the things that happens
is that u.s politicians when they talk
about china they
don't actually have a very good idea of
what the chinese communist party is
they're more using it as a mirror to
reflect
the us but in this case because of the
supply chain issue i think this might be
something where
there's a concerted effort to bring back
american manufacturing interesting
people just need to buy american more
yeah
maybe maybe we need more uh
philanthropists we need more nonprofits
we need more industry to focus on
american products at american costs we
need think tanks
yeah new independent think tanks
all right bobby bob says should the u.s
break up would there be any negative
effect on china
such as u.s businesses leaving i think
if the u.s broke up that would be like
the best thing that ever happened for
the chinese communist party
they'd have a party they would have real
communist parties well that's why i
wonder about
you know do they want to influence this
culture war
they do absolutely yeah i mean i think i
don't know that they're directly doing
it but like they definitely
want to play it up they want to use it
whenever they can because
it weakens the us right and it's in it's
in the sense of
marxist class struggle it is pitting one
group against another group
and so again i wouldn't say the
communist party is behind it
necessarily but they certainly like it
and it certainly
fits the way that the communist party
would do things if they were to try to
sow discord within china
all right turk longwall says tim a
question for your guests can anyone
please comment on how you think a hot
war would play out between them
and us great show smash the like button
a hot war um well it depends on whether
or not they have
taiwan or not uh at the moment
uh china is not in a
i don't think they could really sustain
like a full-on
war with the united states uh with
taiwan the us has access to the chinese
coastline
there's support from the quad
an alliance that's been building up
between the u.s
india japan and australia which i wonder
what the
administration is going to do about that
alliance but also just
in the event of a hot war it would
become impossible for any
american industry to work with
china and then china loses its access to
money
well i think that's a big one so also
um it would be likely a naval war uh
and right now the u.s still has naval
superiority in the pacific
but the u.s indo-pacific commander just
came out and said that china might get
parody by 2026 wow
uh because they're really building they
have more ships
and submarines yeah so i mean in some
ways like
if a hot war would happen the sooner it
happened the better it would be for the
us because the longer
like it just gives the chinese communist
party time
to build up the military and so you're
saying double the military budget
i mean i think that they have to take
the military
and they are talking about this uh and
take it the focus away from the middle
east
and you know go back to focusing on the
pacific
yeah when the us made the shift to
middle east fighting the
the navy became support for the ground
troops and in that time
that the navy was kind of being pushed
to the side in the u.s
that's what china focused on right
china's anti-ship
ballistic missiles already have a
considerably longer range than u.s
anti-ship missiles which if you think
about what that means in an actual
ship to ship warfare is the chinese
ships can get their missiles off much
sooner and sink the american ships
before the american ships can do
anything
right but the solution isn't to double
the mil the us military no i was just
kidding right i mean like
it would be much easier to just stop
investing in china
you're saying we should blow up china
now before
i'm kidding i'm kidding uh
we alright we got samuel pyle says tim
you are wrong about gen z
as a zoomer myself i would i would say
that at least 60
of us are conservative we most are
afraid to speak out
the reason most of us are cl closeted is
because most of the people who have the
authority around us hate anyone who has
right-leaning views
most of us are anti-porn because it's
affected us negatively from a young age
uh well then i would just say perhaps
i am wrong and you are more conservative
i have pointed out that the pew research
shows is a slight
movement towards conservative for the
first time in like four generations
but then uh you have to be brave
i suppose and just speak out what's the
worst is gonna happen
you gotta learn how to actually hunt for
your food oh heavens like humans had to
do that for thousands tens of thousands
of years hundreds of thousands of years
i guess you know my thing is that having
grown up in a rough and tumble area and
being homeless i'm like what's the worst
someone could do to me
they're not going to hit me and even if
they did is that really the word is that
it
you know you get a scrape look if you've
got people around you that are abusing
you and saying insane things
then just simply stop leave ignore them
just don't engage with these kind of
people
stick nukem says i own a shop called
texas holster solutions
i'd like to send you a holster for one
of your pistols who can i email about
this
also keep up the work y'all the show was
100 graphene lol
if you go to timcast.com i believe in
the contact uh
area there's emails but there's also a
po box address if you'd like to send
stuff
all right justin bookman says this is a
very this is very off topic but i'm
getting out of trucking
looking for something to work from home
you guys are the smartest people that i
know what do you suggest
tim doth read the news and let's slip
the ian of war we are guerrilla
all right uh working from home
here's here's what you do uh i had this
this guy who was super rich told me
what's something that you're an expert
on that is a common
concern of people really easy example
would be
like dating most people being a man or
woman
want to have some like better
understanding of dating so what he said
was
if you're good if you have good insights
and you're a good person and you want to
help people
you simply write a small book and then
you advertise it on
facebook and google you find out what
your price point is
uh per advertisement so if it takes five
dollars worth of ads to sell one book
sell it for five dollars and fifty cents
and you've automated the system and then
you make passive income from one book
you've written
and it could seriously be like 50 pages
and so he explained to me that
you know one of his paths was he had
done things in his life like he was he
worked out he trained
and then he realized he was actually
pretty proficient in this very amateur
but he wrote a book about what he did
and said
not medical advice i'm just a guy here's
my ideas and he made a million dollars a
year
so there you go shelly we should write a
book if you guys wrote a book called
china uncensored
and it was just not even that long and
it said you know understanding the basic
facts about china and what you need to
know
and then you put it up you just do like
ads on google or facebook or whatever
it's automated so it takes you know if
five dollars in ads gets you a thousand
views or whatever
and every thousand views gets you one
book sale five dollars and fifty cents
and you're making 50 cents every for
every thousand views so it's just
automatically
pulling in money eventually everybody's
read your book and then you know what do
you do after that you gotta write
something else but you know there you go
[Laughter]
you make a million dollars all right
ed says tim the usa is actually being
censored by the ccp
remember facebook twitter and google
hired the firm responsible for the great
ccp censorship firewall
to tailor their their algorithm to
prevent right-wing extremism
have you guys heard that i know we
mentioned this uh the last time we were
on the show that
there was a case of uh one of the
facebook
fact checkers um being tied to some
company that was
getting funding somehow or another
through china i don't remember all the
details
but i know he did talk about that but
there was genuinely a concern about that
that these fact checkers that
they have they get money from somewhere
but there is a lot of
ai research going on in china like
google you know
they did shut down their dragonfly
censored search app but google is
in china now doing ai and they're not
making a big public splash about it but
like google wants to be in china because
they have access to enormous amounts of
data
there's no like user privacy
restrictions in china
and so google's working with chinese
companies to build up google's own ai
systems and no doubt google
is or will be at some point intending to
use that
ai technology developed in china with
chinese companies and chinese data and
then use that
for its american customers
is that a direct connection of the
communist party using it to censor
americans
i don't think there's a direct
connection there but there's certainly
some you know just with it within a few
steps there's some connection to china
association with an authoritarian regime
always pulls the democracy down
it makes it less free yeah all right
nova zero says china uncensored gang
how much damage do you predict xiao bai
zhang and kami la will do to the
entire aipac region oh oh okay who
there's one more i say did you notice
how allied nations have been slowly
cutting out the us in their dealings
that i pronounced it horribly i'd
imagine right yeah
yes that is beautiful um
i i i have how do you say something over
the name
isn't he trying to like make chinese out
of joe biden and
yes yeah oh i see yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh camila i didn't notice that
yeah i was just like oh i mean you know
joe biden talks about re-establishing
relations with allies and i think
you know there's some degree that he's
trying to do this especially in western
europe
where it seems like we haven't actually
lost any allies over the last four years
but
certainly there's been some diplomatic
tensions there
there has however been a lot of progress
since 2017
uh building up alliances in for example
the asia pacific region
such as the quad india japan australia
and the us working together to counter
the uh the danger of the chinese
communist party and their military
so there have been a lot of alliances
that also central and eastern europe
oh yeah actually the last four years
i've seen a lot of
uh helping develop relationships with
central industry in europe to counter
the pressure that they've been getting
from china to counter the investment
from china
uh even just to some degree in in parts
of africa
u.s money trying to counter the
influence of china although i'm not sure
that's been super successful
but like you know the the whole thing
about
you know we lost all our alliances and
now we have to get them back
i think that's that's not an accurate
picture
it's just that certain alliances have
been strengthened
and certain alliances have been weakened
but the u.s hasn't
lost any allies except maybe china i
mean i would argue that's probably a
good ally to lose if you're going to
lose one uh
but like you know things have changed
things have shifted
and then you know europe are they trying
to work with
you know do they want to work with joe
biden and kamala harris
like yeah on on some things they want to
work with the us on climate change and
they want to get the iran deal back
um but you know they signed a big trade
deal with china the eu signed a trade
uh a preliminary trade deal outline with
china without consulting the us which
was a bit of a slap in the face
because the administration asked them to
wait yeah it had been under works for
years
um was heading somewhere and yeah they
ignored the biden
administration's request well before the
they were the administration saying
we're almost in power just wait until
yeah
but uh but these alliances do take time
and six weeks is not enough time i don't
believe to see
what the trajectory of the biden
administration is going to be to build
up or destroy
yeah eric miller says hilariously
youtube put put in my recommendations
the movie big trouble in little china
also if texas has a problem with the
caravan send them to dc
there you go yeah because uh china
uncensored is in the title so
you know they'll just take the keyword
and then you get
it's a fun movie there you go
all right coop diggity says i love y'all
i'll watch this later be safe ian i
disagree often with your viewpoints but
often i find you have a unique viewpoint
i haven't thought of
lydia thanks for being awesome and
pushing buttons and tim thanks well
ian's on the show tonight
and luke is on vacation so we've got the
china and censored crew but there you go
bubbly is the good says my buddy dylan
witcher was banned from china
when we were in high school because he
started a massive free tibet website in
2002.
we were fighting this for decades my
first political fight was tibet
interesting great yeah didn't they they
removed that it was like they did the
new top gun movie top gun maverick
yeah and the patch on tom cruise's back
they removed tibet
it was taiwan taiwan taiwan and japan
yeah
wow well you know you gotta please the
uh the ccp so
public's the good also says fbi says the
entirety of
all one million of conservatives are
under investigation
antifa terrorists are all out of jail i
disagree on the cultural
cultural revolution here i have actual i
have actually emails between dnc
congress and antifa
so you you disagree is it because they
hate each other or something
questioning china says secret police
were invented 600 years ago in china
ming dynasty google eastern depot
do you guys know what about that i
haven't heard of eastern depot
i also imagine secret police have been
around for longer than 600 years
but that does sound like an interesting
thing stephen valdez says chris i had a
super patreon account with you guys for
seven months but never got my name at
the end of the video as promised
messaged you guys three times on patreon
love your work but was hoping you could
respond
well i missed that message yeah shoot us
an email at
china uncensored gmail.com and uh we'll
take care of it sorry about that
yeah definitely we get we get the job
done here at tim cast iron we make sure
we hold
we hold the powerful elites to account
truth to power
i mean for a long time our team is
basically like
you know the three of us plus one video
editor so
honestly the truth is we do drop the
ball sometimes and and
we're sorry about that and i'm the
producer so really it's my problem and
not chris's problem but definitely a big
thank you to everyone who supports uh
our work
uh it would not our china and censored
would not be possible without
uh the viewer support on patreon yeah i
mean we're we're a really small
company and it's mostly viewer support
and not youtube ad revenue that's
actually
running so thank you thank you for that
contribution i'm sorry i missed that
garnet says call chinese organ
harvesting what it is
farming humans bring it up to your vegan
friends ask them if they won't eat meat
for moral reasons
why the heck are you supporting a
president who is a-okay with butchering
uyghurs like kettle
yikes i'm sure that'll be great dinner
conversation with people who are not
particularly politically active
so you got some friends eating like you
know kale chip salad or something and
you're like
so you don't eat meat and they're like
no i don't meat then why do you support
biden you
butcher and they're gonna be like what
no but i do think it's it's a really
fair point you know body needs to
i think biden should have come out right
away and said this is genocide no
question about it it must be stopped
he on the campaign trail he did call
genocide or
his campaign did i don't know that he
actually did he never said the word yeah
the g word yeah
mao de mighty says my ears been ringing
all night but i wear this cowl like
bruce wayne though
uncensored tim read my minds pm message
oh pmessage thanks for quoting this mao
you got it
supra says they call it the patriot act
because that is whom it goes after
aha there it is jake mahani says the ccp
is arming iran
allowing iran to conduct proxies in the
middle east biden is allowing china to
commit genocide
while simultaneously gearing up for
reunification of taiwan
yeah it sounds like things are pretty
bad i have to say uh
maybe that's why i'm a little
pessimistic omg puppy says hatred is the
most accessible and comprehensive of all
the unifying agents
mass movements can rise and spread
without belief in a god
but never without a belief in a devil
eric hoffer the true believer
interesting christopher says you said
you were planning on making a new site
and new content
would this be free or eligible for tim
cast members or a whole new subscription
uh so we're planning on making a network
of different websites
and it's one subscription for all of
them so quite literally
my my goal is if you are a member of
timcast.com i just want to make sure we
just keep making more and more stuff for
you
and ultimately have one parent brand
that
you know if you're a member of it grants
you access to basically everything
there are going to be some things
because they'll be joint ventures where
they'll be entirely separate
subscriptions and websites so
i think the new show we're planning on
doing will not be part of this because
i'm doing with other people
and it'll have to be its own thing so
but ultimately that's what i want to do
i want to do
shows original sketch comedy documentary
and have it just be part of one big
brand so ultimately
everybody who is already a member at
temco.com we'll get access to all this
really cool stuff we're planning to
build
quite literally the membership you have
that money is
going towards expanding hiring new
people
we actually have uh some people coming
out soon to interview about jobs because
we're gonna be doing a lot more
producing a lot more
and then hopefully that helps us make
more money and start more companies
so uh if you really like the show then
go to timecast.com become a member
smash that like button and share the
podcast and
aside from that i've got the other my
other youtube channels as well but we're
trying to do more and more and more
to put it simply claymore says human is
the most racist word there can be
words of racism are words designed to
defied people
who had man racist i say it should be
the rights of men
interesting dom uh let's see is it what
is it
dom nall 1989 says has china uncensored
seen
j.j mccolo's video on falun gong in
which he mentioned china uncensored as
falun gong propaganda
oh smackdown i never actually watched
that
but we we are completely independently
produced we have no
connection to falun gong any more than
we have connection to the jews which
is something i've been accused of as
well that's so
weird uh yeah there was uh i think i
mentioned this to you guys last time
there was apparently some campaign
hitting up medium
like small size youtubers with decent
followings maybe like tens of thousands
where they would say hey just upload
this video to your youtube channel
that's all and we'll pay you you know
500 bucks or 600 bucks and it was some
guy explaining why the falun gong was a
dangerous cult
and he was like complaining that they
were performing in new york and that
everyone should go and complain to the
performing arts center to get falun gong
banned or whatever
that was really weird when i when i saw
that i'm like who would who would upload
to their channel a video from some
random person but also like
like it should be a red flag if the
authoritarian communist party
is persecuting a group like that should
be a signal that
like you shouldn't also be persecuting
these people in a free country like
maybe there's something wrong with the
group that's doing the persecuting right
right
weird so yeah i mean
it's just you know but but but people
people go after us and that's whatever
you know all right caramel says hey tim
thanks for reading my super chat
oddly bandersnatchy but it's fine anyway
cuomo definitely performed genocide
am i crazy for finding this obvious af
cuomo killed fifteen thousand people it
wasn't just him
there's some other governors as well and
they were and they were warned of this
so
man it's it's it's a creepy time man i
tell you that
all right anything about texas please
talk about 3f and the ccp stated ames to
literally destroy the united states
in your opinion are we in immediate
danger
are we so compromised from the inside
that all hope is lost
i don't know what the three f's are 3f
no idea
and the ccp stated aims to destroy the
united states is that a thing
uh well they're very clear about uh
struggling against the united states
that the united states is the enemy
they are the whole unrestricted warfare
thing yeah
uh yeah so i mean the chinese communist
party is already at war with the united
states we talked about the last time
unrestricted warfare
i mean we're we're being slammed by
cyber war i mean china is going after
our infrastructure
that's one aspect of it yeah um
financial warfare
information drug warfare information
warfare it's a big one
all right let's see what we got
alexander hale says cuomo's high
approval rating
is about as legit as biden's approval
rating it's fake just like all the polls
before the election
was fortified yeah published the good
says we haven't even begun to fight
john paul jones the original alex jones
not advocating violence fbi historically
accurate
that's what he said was it he was a he
was a in his ship and they were
firing cannons at each other and yeah
she was like
just slammed and he was like we have not
yet begun to fight
we haven't even begun to fight famous
quote
lester leo says u.s should learn how
taiwanese handle elections
taiwan treats voting security and
transparency seriously given how china
china always wants to influence it
interesting
we were there for the taiwan election
and they have a
pretty good system yeah yeah security
a a couple things about taiwan election
security uh
number one you have to show up in person
and show your id
uh number two paper ballots they're
paper ballots
uh number three uh at the end of the
voting day
uh anyone from the community can come in
and stand there physically and be an
observer
there's not selected observers there
anyone just can randomly arbitrarily
show up
and they can watch the ballots being
counted read aloud
and tallied on a board not just allowed
in the building
but but they can actually see it yeah
the observers can actually observe
right yeah and so uh there's for the the
in the in-person
voting id uh clear uh chain with paper
ballots and the observers
uh it's it's very very hard to commit
fraud there
now the the flip side of this obviously
is that you know if you can't vote by
mail you could say well
there's maybe some disenfranchisement
and i think that's true and every
country has to figure out what's the
balance
between security and ensuring the
integrity of the election
and making sure that more people have
access to voting
taiwan has made that choice to ensure
security because they're under so much
threat
from the communist party and other
countries may at least want to look to
that model for
inspiration uh to some degree and i
think also taiwan's only been voting
since like 1996.
so interesting they they treasure like
for presidential elections so they
they treasure their democracy a lot and
i think it was
you know all of us felt quite moved like
watching the whole process of like
people bringing their kids to watch the
vote count and things like that their
democracy yeah it was
it was really amazing and yeah like
everybody gets the day off to vote
but you have to go in person so like
people flew from overseas to go back to
taiwan to vote wow yeah
justin wheeler says will tim cast ever
have an
app we are working on it right now
actually so we know that most people who
watch and listen are doing it on mobile
and so we are
trying to build that mobile app so it's
really easy for members to just log in
and do all that really cool stuff so
yeah nick timko says i got my wisdom
teeth out this week and
watching your podcast has really helped
keep my mind off the pain
oh i hear that i'm glad i had a with i
had a really really bad impacted wisdom
tooth this one and
getting it taken out was like
the dentist it looked like he was doing
you know street construction
and it was i was shaking and sweaty and
just like for like three days i was like
all these painkillers was like the worst
pain ever so isn't it nice to know that
your show is less
bad than that yes just a little bit
a little bit a little bit less bad than
getting your wisdom tooth ripped out of
your face it's a compliment
please have us back all right a horrible
gamer
says shelly how did you become aware and
start spreading the word about china
what is the story of you partnering up
with agent smith against china
uh that's classified i see but um
my parents came from well i was born in
china and
my parents came to the us in the 80s as
grad students
and then they brought me to america and
we were all in the u.s by the time the
1989 tiananmen square massacre happened
and my dad before he had gotten a
scholarship from the chinese government
to study
get his phd in america so he was
supposed to go back
and he was he was intent on bringing us
back until the tiananmen square
massacre happened and then he basically
just was so furious like the chinese
students in america at that time
like they were they marched in the
streets of the us
against the chinese government that's
how that's how bad that was
and uh basically we ended up staying in
the us because the
uh bush administration at the time gave
chinese students who had been in the u.s
and protested during the massacre
like uh like amnesty because the idea
was that you could
be you know if you went back to china
you could be persecuted for protesting
in the us
wow so crazy yeah all right
uh al or ai whichever one says chrome
wouldn't kill anyone
anyone in medicine can tell you people
can't stay in hospitals and are sent to
nursing homes for long-term care it's a
cost thing
except when they have the javits center
and the mercy available
and empty and the nursing home said you
will introduce the virus here and then
cuomo is like
geez what have we done we better hide
the numbers otherwise we might get
investigated by federal prosecutors
that's literally what happened there it
is he killed him
and he doesn't take responsibility for
it all right that guy says
do you think if china attacks taiwan or
has a war on
its eastern front that india would
attack china
that's an interesting question um we've
definitely seen
india standing up to the chinese
communist party
in a way that it had not done um
in recent history uh not just
uh not just on the border where there's
been confrontations between indian
troops and
chinese troops where indian soldiers
were actually killed last year
uh but also in indian society there's
been a huge ban
on many types of chinese apps there is a
growing
cultural awareness of you know after
taiwan
india could be one of the next targets
uh china is working with pakistan
uh it's building potential military
ports all around
india what's called the string of pearls
and the idea is that
china will be coming after india not
right now
well piece by piece on the board once
the us collapses
into you know the democrat states in the
north for the most part join canada and
then the rest become jesus land as the
meme dictates
then china won't have any unified
opposition for the most part
and then they can shift their focus to
india maybe australia
well it is still a risk to you can't do
it too quick otherwise
india and japan and australia maybe
south korea though
there was a whole thing about election
interference in south korea involving
china but that's another story
uh yeah step one step at a time
all right let's see we'll take one more
right here rita ho says maybe
maybe two more invited taiwanese kol to
talk about election integrity
and how to fight information warfare
that sounds pretty cool yeah
what's a k-o-l yeah look that up key
opinion leader
oh did you just come up with that no
that's not that she knows that's actual
abbreviation for
oh okay very cool cool all right gabriel
mc
mcleod we'll do this last one says the
potential for diplomacy with china
implies those in a position
to be diplomatic have any interest in
enacting change for the good of the
world instead of simply maintaining the
status quo
all right all right we'll leave it there
but if you haven't already you guys got
to smash that like button on your way up
before you go you've got to you've got
to reach over and you've got to give
that little button a tap because it
really does help the channel
and you should subscribe hit that
notification bell and share the show
with your friends
share the clips we put up clips you know
every single day from the show
and uh check us out on all podcast
platforms itunes spotify etc
you can follow me on all social media
platforms at tim cast my other channels
are youtube.comtimcast and
youtube.comcastnews this show is live
monday through friday at 8pm so we will
be back monday
but thank you all so much for hanging
out smash that like button i'll say it
again and
uh do you guys want to mention your
social media and your show yeah you can
follow us
on youtube.com china uncensored as well
as
slash america uncovered you'll get a lot
of really interesting information about
the us
and china uh you can also find us on
instagram twitter
and facebook shelly you have a very nice
twitter
uh my twitter is at sheljong
s-h-e-l-z-h-a-n-g
uh and we also did you say the podcast i
didn't i always forget the podcast so
uh we also have a podcast china
unscripted on youtube and
all the podcast platforms oh very cool
do you want to mention you have if you
have twitter or anything or
uh nope no i don't he helps us make all
the other things
well there we go and i am sour patch
lids here in the corner you can find me
on twitter
at sour patch lids as well as on mines
sour bachelorettes
and i'm also on instagram and gab at
real sour patch lids
everybody thank you all so much for
hanging out i don't think we're gonna
have a a special extended segment
tonight
but uh and it's always because i'm
trying to do something for the weekends
where literally every single friday i'm
like we're gonna go to the range and
we're gonna film it and then we don't
because people are leaving you know luke
was on vacation we had we had the dude
from phoenix ammo here and we were going
to go and it was going to be awesome
film some drills and then luke is like
i'm going on vacation see you later and
i was like all right i guess so we'll
try and get something up this weekend
as an actual on-the-ground video vlog
type thing and we are going to be
launching a new version of the website
cleaner upgraded it uh you know we
started the website we got members the
members provided revenue for the company
that allow us to upgrade and we're
investing it all back in
so you guys rock thank you all so much
for for hanging out and we will see you
on monday bye guys
you